alright so our next speaker is John
Hoffman about automatic resource bound
analysis and linear optimization yeah so
this is something completely different
and i work in programming languages so i
guess this counts as an application here
and so the the tile at least part of the
title of this virtuous beyond worst case
analysis and analysis I mean usually
mean analysis of algorithms and then
when i say resource bound analysis I
mean analysis of programs of software
which is in some sense very similar and
some other sense also very different
from from analysis of algorithms so they
give you a little bit of motivation why
are we interested in resource usage of
programs so first of all there are
safety critical systems and a resource
usage is a very important problem there
so you remember for instance this
unintended cell eration and to your
Akash where your car which just speed up
you can't break any more people died
because of this issue there was a
lawsuit and expert witness related this
problem to stack overflow so this is
related to memory usage another example
i have here's is about timing so the AEC
three train was produced by siemens and
Joanie and the delivery of the train was
delayed for over a year because of
timing issues with a software if you
would hit the brake it would take more
than one second till the signal gets
sent from soft words with actual breaks
was considered to be unsafe had to be
fixed but even outside of
safety-critical systems resource usage
is of course very important so you see
like in a lot of like systems and big
systems you see a performance box so
when's the worthless healthcare.gov
website that you might remember that
what total disaster had many issues but
one of the main issues was there that
day Caillou it was too slow another
example I have is from a project I do
with Google there we work with a team
that is doing the back end of the the
google apps and they have
fairly regularly issues when they you
know change the code that they you know
and they ship it to their servers and
then they run out of resources so they
want to run their servers at like a very
high capacity and if the like you know
say memory usage goes up a little bit
then the silver start failing and they
can run regression tests overnight but
they cannot run a performance for
crashing tests so what they have to do
is literally do like a binary search of
the changes they made to the code to
find out what course like the increase
in memory usage so finally so that also
very important on this problem of
resource usage and software security so
there are lot of ulnar abilities based
on resource usage so I have selected to
hear one is called algorithmic
complexity vulnerabilities where an
attacker can trigger an unusual
worst-case behavior in your system so
for instance you know you have a server
and you use a hash table and an attacker
could send packet they get all hash in
the same pockets and so it's very slow
it can do its job anymore something like
input of deaths or if or some things
like wait for that the other thing is
like side channels where an attacker can
learn secret information from the
resource behavior of the program so that
can be like time usage like you know
when you compare password character by
character you know you can see how many
you hit and you can even learn then the
password over over the network another
thing is like when you have size of
encrypted packets that somebody can
observe and this is like a fingerprint
you know of the things you clicked on in
your form and that's another project
we're doing them with star power that's
actually a fairly large DARPA program
where they specifically look at these
two problems and you know give us
software and we have to find these
vulnerabilities so so the the the
problem we're looking at is very similar
to analysis of algorithms so we've given
a program P and we would like to know
what is the worst-case resource
consumption as a function
of the sizes of the inputs and a
resource you can we clock cycles heap
space energy usage and in these more
motivating examples I mentioned you see
that like asymptotic bounds are not good
enough you want concrete constant factor
preferably on concrete hardware and this
is kind of like similar as what Duncan's
dozen in the art of computer program
where he also has like concrete constant
factors for the smokes architecture but
I mean you can't ask the developer just
do like such an analysis for the codes
we would like to do that automatically
and of course this is an undecidable
problem but you know the goal is to come
up with some technology that works well
for lot of programs and particularly for
programs that people write in practice
so the research challenges here are you
know very different from analysis of
algorithms so we you know usually don't
analyze you know program that contains a
new algorithm for you know graph
isomorphism or something like that you
know that the programs we have are very
simple but you know we have to deal with
things like you know compilation
hardware caches and you know library
code and runtime systems so and this is
general like more about the mechanics
compositionality you know of things and
not so much of having very complicated
algorithms implemented so yeah one thing
that there's very important is to ensure
that these automatic analyses are
compositional in the sense that like you
know if it works for one function and
another function you know and you plug
these functions together and there's
some size change in your data you know
that you can still get it get get it
automatically get a bound for those and
another thing we have to work with is
figuring on complex language features
concurrency a high or data structure so
these are like the main challenges so
you're thinking about and about your how
they're related to to the workshop so I
mentioned already if you interpret the
title as you know being beyond
worst-case analysis of algorithms so
okay here you look at you know
is kissing as a self programs and the
challenges are a kind of like very
different but they're two other have
like a point here i want to make so one
is that we face similar challenges that
like you face when you were when you
when you describe a worst case but you
know then like you know people come to
us and say like okay the data that we
have you know we don't see this
worst-case behavior we want you know
something other than the worst case and
it's but unclear what that is so that's
what i was hoping to find here you know
some inspiration of you know what what
that could be and so that's what I find
very interesting about the workshop
there is another connection so when we
all like and technique that I use when I
do the automatic bound analysis we
reduce the problem of bound analysis to
LP solving and there we have such an
instance where the behavior we see in
practice is much better than the
worst-case behavior so we use simplex
but the so the worst case would be
exponential about the instances of the
linear programs that we generate have
usually a linear behavior so they can be
solved in linear time and practice so
there's like an instance where you want
to have you know the analysis of our
system where you want to have something
that goes beyond worst-case analysis
okay good so yeah that's a quick
motivation to give you a bit of an of an
idea what this is all about so I want to
go a bit into the technicalities of this
analysis you know how we do that how we
get the balance I can only you know give
you touch on a few points to give you an
idea of how we do that and then I want
to hopefully convince you that this
works surprisingly well and in practice
so we have an implementation and you
know I show you but oh how they work
some concrete examples and finally I
talk
about the linear programs that we get
from from the analysis okay so just
really quickly here's what what we want
to do so we start with some source code
we want to get like a symbolic resource
bounty or something like that here a
formula that depends on the input sizes
but we have to take into account the
compiler and the runtime system and we
do that by defining the former cost
semantics of the program at the higher
level we then do our automatic analysis
and we do interestingly a type based
analysis so we do like some type
inference and I'll explain that we get a
type derivation and this type duration
can be seen as a proof of the bound and
you can even like you to attach that to
your code and ship it with with your
coat and the benefit of the setup is
that like we can prove the analysis
sound with respect to this cost
semantics here so we have a you know
very clear salma theorem and because
it's a type system it's very
compositional right you can have like
and in the type you had kind of a
library and in the types you see all the
resource costs and we have as i said
this efficient LP solving so the idea of
the analysis is to automate amortized
analysis so what we do is we you know
you or you can think of a program as you
know having like states and transitions
between the states and at each state we
define a potential function that map's
the memory at the state to a
non-negative number and for each
transition in the program we ensure that
the potential at the starting state is
sufficient to cover the cost of the
transition and the potential at the next
state and if you do that for all the
transitions in your program then you
know that the potential you have at the
starting state of the program is an
upper bound on the cost of the execution
no matter what path you take swoops
through the program but now we want to
automate this using a type system so
what we have to do is we have to because
we cannot you know generate like in
arbitrary potential functions so what we
have to do is we have to fix the format
these potential functions and this you
can view as a basis like in the knee
algebra right we want to use like a
linear constraint solving to to do this
and then the type rules are like you
know local manipulations of these
constraints of the basis so thats a how
it works and the potential is really
given by the types in the system so
sounds kind of complicated but it is
very intuitive so let's look at an
example so here you have a pen for
persistent lists and let's say you know
we are interested in memory usage his
face usage right so if you want to do
this append rail its persistence list so
we have to copy over here this list X
and we say like you know for for each
list element you know we need to heap
cells one for the data one for the
pointer to the next so how this will
look at them when we have you penned XY
if we walk through this list X and we
copy it over right and here we have like
length 3 and this is the result of a pen
and three times to six so six is a huge
space usage of this program and what I
want to do now is you know I want to
show you how we can reason about it with
potential but before I do that I want to
show you a slightly more interesting
program here so that you can see the
compositionality of this thing so here
you have two calls to a pent okay first
we append X to Y you get this list t and
then we append te to a list that here
and so the the bound I mean it's still
like you can do the math it's not too
hot but as I said we want to do this
automatically so now we have to n where
n is the length of X and then we have to
n plus M because that's the length of
tea and it's already like a bit more
complicated because now you have to
figure out you know what Boeing's cheese
automatically so how we do that is we
introduce some potential for every
element in the list so here we're going
to say likely of potential for for you
know every element in
the list X and potential tool for every
element in the list why and you know if
you sum this up this is exactly this
four times n plus 2 times m the boundary
we want to prove and if you want to
prove this bag we kind of like
statically works through the program and
kind of like think about how this
program is executed and here so what's
going to happen is we're going to like
copy over this note see here well when
we execute the appendix why and we have
this potential for so two of these
potential units you know have to be used
up to pay for the creation of this new
node and two are left over and we can
you know assign it to this new list that
we create here and we do that for the
rest of the elements and then you know
we we have this new list here t there's
a result of the first call and now we
have a list where we have two potential
units per element in the list here and
now we can walk over this list here and
can use this potential in the second
call of a pent to pay for the cost so
this is how we set up the analysis and
you can see already you know that this
is something that's easy to automate at
the beginning of the program you don't
know what it is right so you put like
some unknown annotations here and then
you get when you analyze the program
text some inequalities that tell you how
much of this potential you need okay so
yeah what's interesting is that you
never when you do this analysis you
never have to think about the sizes of
the the data structure so that's all
implicit in the analysis and that's why
why it's easy to automate so in a few
one form like that so you can use the
types of food you can do like different
things but here you have the type of app
and you know just as like I you have two
lists and you create a list and then for
this first call of a penned you want to
have this potential
for and then for the first list and
potential annotation tool for the second
list and what you get is a list with
annotation to hear I for the second call
you need a different type but you only
have two potential units units attached
to every element here in the first list
and then everything is used up in
general you can summarize the type by
having like unknown annotations and set
of linear constraints here and depending
on the call site you need to have a
different type values that you need to
get both constants and the length of B
list or whatever data structures yes how
can you sort of you know recognize which
situation or any but one of them is a
growing quantity and yes how do you know
how exactly I'll come to that I mean the
trick is here already you take into
account the length of the list I mean
I'll come to two polynomial things in
the moment but that's an important point
here I mean we say like you know you
have two potential elements per element
in the list so you have two times and
alrighty and and so that's exactly you
know thanks for asking this question so
that's exactly the thing I want to talk
about next so how can we you know extent
this to polynomial so that works like
very well for like you know a linear
bounce you get this composition ala trp
solving and so on and the interesting
thing is the same thing can work for
multivariate polynomial bounds so I
another point I want to make a show how
this works for 44 heap space here but
you can really do the same thing for
every resource metric that you give me
forever you know constant cost you give
me for like additions multiplications or
whatever constructs you have in your
programming languages parametric and
that and so I next time we'll talk about
like how we can do the same thing for
polynomial behavior and yeah this is
something that that's relatively new and
we can even do things like you know em
times and squared like these
multivariate things and and much more
than that really to say it works for for
polynomial is a bit of an understatement
so okay so just start with an example so
let's say maybe not so quick let's say
we have quicksort my quick sort of
course like how some are portrayed
behavior and now we have a program where
you first append to list and then feed
it into quicksort so the bug you get at
the end is already fairly complicated so
you know you have like these mix factors
here you know because it's a quadratic
and & M plus n so that's a bound you get
here I think I look at number of
evaluation steps and that's about we
automatically derive with with our
system so how this will look in the
system i said like it's a bit like
linear algebra right where you now have
multiple annotations for lists so here
for instance you have you know something
linea something you know this is a well
this is a constant one here actually
this is a linear one you've seen before
and this is a quadratic one so the
quadratic one here is actually a
binomial coefficient because these
binomial coefficients behave very nicely
under like discreet derivation and
that's what you need in the system when
you you know have size changes in your
data structures and you see also here
you have kind of like a different basis
depending on the data so here you know
you have a pair of lists so in our type
system you have like all these different
factors here you know for like linea en
linea NM quadratic and n this mixed one
here quadratic and m and this is kind of
like the basis you have for for this
particular type and the system
automatically kind of like this cover
this convolution formula for binomial
coefficients so this is nothing we you
know put into the system that's just
like in these local linear constraints
and the system kind of like discovered
this in the end the type inference which
i think is
remarkable and yeah so the if you have
already you know the bound for quicksort
then kind of like this is the bound q
you get 4444 your whole program yeah I
wanna so this just to to give you a bit
of an impression and of course you want
to have like you know certain algebraic
properties for for your basis and so
it's a it's an interesting question you
know what function set to pick for for
the spaces so the main thing you want to
have is that you have like a good way of
you know expressing that your potential
is non-negative and we usually do that
by just having non negative coefficients
in our like cone that we have and the
other thing you want is you want good
closure properties so when you when the
sizes of your data structures change you
know so if you have quadratic potential
you get like a linear spill that you can
later use up and so you want to produce
simple linear constraints so you want to
have like a good function set and what
we developed is this Sigma Pi formula
where you kind of like in your data
structure you sum up over all order to
ports that you can form and then for
each tuple you can have again like a
polynomial cost the simplest form of
that is where you just say for each
tuple you have some constant cost and
then you get the binomial coefficients
but you can't have more complex stuff so
here you have like a few examples or
what I resource polynomials so one thing
you can for instance get is something
like this so this is a bound you get for
sorting algorithm where each comparison
takes linear time so then you get the
sum over all the pairs you can form with
your list and for each pair you have a
linear cost ok questions so far
yeah logarithmic behavior is that that's
something that's very complicated to get
I mean you can set up an analysis that
works well let's say you know for merge
sort it gives you an N log n bound but
then if you want to have this
compositionality this is very difficult
to get when you have lager logarithmic
factors because here for for polynomial
I mean it's you have to get this nice
closure property that you know the
result of a polynomial computations a
polynomial you can plug it in again you
get a polynomial and with the logarithm
it's it's not quite like that also like
when you get the spill yeah heaps you
have something for a technocratic
potential you make it smaller get the
linear spill and so on foil for the
logarithm I mean what you get is not
uniform in some size that you have you
get something like you know 1 over N and
we don't quite know what what to do with
it so we have a few ideas what to do for
for logarithmic but we don't have a good
solution exponential interestingly is
easy that works work very well but
logarithmic is very hard to to get set
up log in to be your basic thing yeah
well yeah we were here we tried that but
its difficulty I mean something we work
on right now I mean you can you can have
some solutions so I mean something we
word i also like experimenting with us
if you trust at like a new variable to
the program that's just like a ghost
variable and that's just you know always
like log n for for some list and you
maintain it in the program and that
would be also like a way to to get it
but yeah I'm not too happy with it so
yeah I would say it's still like an open
question you got other questions yeah so
now 22 to automate the the analysis what
you have to do is you fix a maximal
degree of your balance so that you
cannot get like a finite basis for every
type and then you attach like to to you
know your type derivation if you want
unknown coefficient
to you know all your types and then you
have type rules so here for instance
them I did that guy we have like this
pair of lists and some coefficients and
then you kind of like get these linear
constraints depending on you know what
you do with your your data and that like
we solve with no peace over and of
course we minimize in the objective the
initial potential it's nice you can even
say like okay you want to first minimize
you know the cubic coefficients and then
you do like this iterative solving at
annual objective and you know so the add
new constraint based on on the object if
you got them than you you you solve the
quadratic ones and linear one so that
works really nicely and efficiently okay
yeah so I ya there would be much more to
talk about for instance you know when
you go beyond lists when you have
user-defined types tree like stuff and
so on but yet but I one hour like move
on and show you how the system works and
and what we can do with it more
questions about the technical stuff
ok so we implement the system for subset
of mo camel so this is like a it's a
real project so we have 1200 line are
twelve thousand lines of code right now
and we use CLP from the corner project
as our solver sometimes we also use
cplex but we found they are like both
some pretty comparable on the simple
constraints that we have we support a
lot of language features i mentioned
user-defined inductive types you have
higher order function we have parallel
evaluations something I didn't talk
about side effects I didn't talk about
and we can also do lower bounds with
with this analysis which is interesting
for some of these applications you can
try this out online find the link on my
webpage so here I have two sets of
benchmarks here that this is what I call
micro benchmarks where we just you know
implement some textbook algorithms with
with a system so here you see for
instance quicksort the derived balint is
like a quadratic bound and here you see
the performance of the analysis so you
see it's a professor numbers here are a
bit outdated I think now they probably
would take all under one second here
with with the current version yeah you
can have volatile complex things so
here's like this insertion saw where you
have like a linear comparison so the
strike you know sorting of strings here
you have Dijkstra's shortest path
algorithm quicksort with arrays some in
place quicksort and yeah these are like
the typical example so oh yeah what we
then of course why we proved is that
these bounts are sound but we don't know
if these bounds are tight so it could be
you know that like i mean i already
mentioned at all or usually what you get
is something that's asymptotically tight
or often
if you can express it if it's polynomial
but then the question is how good are
the constant factors and so what we did
is you know we hear this is all 44 like
steps an hour like semantics and what we
did is we implement like an interpreter
that you know just count the steps as
you run the program and we feel like
worst-case inputs of a quick sort like a
reversely sort a list and the red dots
is what we measure when we run it with
like our worst case examples and the
blue line is the bond that we derive so
for these like high level things like
steps you get tight bounds for for for
for many of the functions so this is
quicksort here here's longest common
subsequence again these blue lines
that's the boundary we derived and the
red dots is what we measured there it's
you know pretty similar what you get for
like an input offer of a fixed size and
it does not depend so much on it here
you have insertion sort again you get
well for for these strings again you get
like a very very good bound for that
okay so the the other benchmarks we did
is like when you just you know get some
existing code and you know run it like
gonna on on a larger code base so yeah
we did that like for a a couple of
things for instance you know the
standard list library we can
automatically analyze most of the
functions or here this is like a C
compiler written in oakham oh this is an
interesting project anyways because it's
a verified c compiler so it's not
written in a camel initially it's
written in the proof assistant and then
the code is extracted Joe Camel so this
is an optimizing c compiler that's
proved to be correct there's a see
compile there's no box and the advantage
we get from this is that the code is
very regular so it works very well with
our tool and you can't of course expect
you know if you have a function let's
say you know like bubble sort that
contains something okay while the list
is
you know not sorted to something I mean
this is something where we have to give
up but if you have something where you
have you know in every function you know
as some size decrease before the
recursive call you know these are the
things we can deal with very well and
that's what you get from from this kind
of thing so yeah so you get like and
often I mean if you know you have like a
language fragment that we support you
get like pretty good results so and also
the the balance you get are often as I'm
totally tied and the constant factors
are also pretty good so this is
something I envision can like could like
really be you know and degrade into to
to like you know realistic environment
where they use of camel where they get
feedback at compilation time okay I one
thing I don't want to talk about but I
want to mention it quickly so what I
have shown you is like how this works
for like these high-level things like
you know number of allocation steps by
what we are often interested in is of
course things like clock cycles and how
can we make this connection and so this
something we did like very recently
where we use machine learning to kind of
like find out okay what's the average
time and the digit takes at the high
level for the compiled code of course
it's like a difficult question to answer
because you have cash effects
instruction pipeline these things but if
you say like okay you know we just want
to know what the average is to give the
developer an idea at the end you know
you can just say like we take a few you
know programs example inputs you know we
set up like this interpreter that just
count the number of additions and then
you know we use linear regression to fit
the curve of like you know this constant
444 edition where's the thing we
measured on some particular hardware and
this is them what we can fit in to our
analysis as a cost semantics you know to
predict
the execution time of new programs and
this works fairly well I mean if you
think about like how crazy it is to do
something like that because you have
these cash effects and so on it works
surprisingly well so here's one of the
examples that are not that great it's a
penned and it's not that great because
you have a lot of memory operations
going on for a pen so the the the whole
cost for the execution of a pen is
basically the cost for the memory
operations as you create this new list
and you have garbage collection right so
garbage collection this is what what
what happens here and the blue thing is
is what we predict and here these are
our like measurements we make a 500
times and this in this like little box
here the second and third quartile of
the measurements and so if you have like
you know function like quicksort this
looks much better because you have less
you know memory going on memory
operations going on compared to the to
the run time mm okay so um I'm sure how
much time to have five more yeah okay
that's good then so you have questions
about this machine learning stuff yeah
this is something that's fairly you that
we are doing right now so okay the last
thing I want to talk about was the LPN
sources that we get so that's also like
an thing that you know might be
interesting for for some of you so the
instances we get up almost network flow
problems but not quite so just as a
reminder so these network flow
constraints how do they look they always
say like ok you have you know some edges
X I you know where you have some flow
inside your note and then you have like
this exchange know these are like the
edges that you know flow out of your
note and then you can also have these
like sources or things where you know
can like have a constant where you can
you know
either like you know get some flow out
of the system or some constant flow into
the system can be positive or negative I
don't know which one is in and out but
it's important and the other thing you
have are these bounds you know on the on
the flow capacities of this Li and you I
here are constants let's say you know
how much flow you have to send through
and you allowed to send through so often
this Li will just be zero okay and yeah
so and I sound like the constraints we
get our kind of similar and so if you
just think of like you know you would
have a program you know we just have
straight line coat you know you have
like you know some like additions and
that would look as follows so you have
like you know what every line you have
some potential queue right and then you
have some cost C and at the next line
you have some you know Q prime so
basically this is exactly what what you
what you get from from this network flow
but then when when you look at programs
and the things are like a bit more
complicated so here this looks like when
you have size change in your program for
instance you know you we have these
lists you know where you have like this
potential that becomes available when
you you know shorten the list by one you
get this potential our you can use it up
so that would be like a constraint it
looks like this one here where we say
like okay the potential you know when
the list gets smaller the constant
potential is the old constant potential
plus this linnaeus bill you get out of
the list so it looks like one of these
network constraints but it's a bit
different in the sense that these add
this edge you get from this like linear
potential that would be your your
network you kind of like allow the flow
to fork basically and you don't have to
split it up so the the linear potential
flows into the
list they got one shorter but it also
flows into the constant potential for
the next one so you have kind of like
this this fork so it's a bit different
i'm not sure if you would count that as
a network flow constraint but maybe you
would I don't know is in another thing
you get in the recursive call so that's
also a bit different from from a network
flow is you want to say basically when
you when you do the recursive call you
want to kind of like close the loop so
you want to say like okay and now again
you have the same potential as at the
beginning of the function so you can you
know just recursively do this cost
accounting so you would have something
like p equals Q and in the network that
would also be a little bit weird so you
would have liked the potential you know
flowing out of a note and then flowing
all into the same note again so that's
how it would look in a network another
thing you have here that's different
from network flow is a conditional
branch so here you can and that's why
you get worst-case balances here you can
have kind of like a waste of potential
rights so you have like now think of
like you have this constant potential
again you know at every line and now you
have a fork in your program a
conditional and then you want to say
like okay the ones potential you have
here must be sufficient you know to
cover for the cost and the first branch
and also switch to cover for the cost in
the second branch but if the cost is
different you know well then you know
that's why its worst case parts on one
branch you have a little bit of waste so
that's all so different from from from
from the network flow but you know it's
it's similar enough and so I'll want to
skip over this this little few details
the the thing that's really different is
a bit of a technicality so if you have
like this function G here let's say you
know it has some portrait a cost yo G X
Y has cost ten times south of x times
the size of wise as humans lists again
or something and now you call this
function G here and by using like the
same variable X twice here ok and now
you have in
situation where you want to like Express
this cost here x squared in terms of
these binomials here so you have to help
do kind of like you know that's if you
want the price you pay for selecting the
binomial coefficients at the basis so
you wouldn't have a lot of work here you
know if this would be like the standard
basis but here we have to do a little
bit of work because we now have to
express this Q times x squared in terms
of these Qi here in the coefficients of
the binomials and so what you get here
is for instance oh yeah q 1 is 1 times q
and q 2 is 2 times Q and the other qks
are there the coefficients are 0 and
these you can you know compute ahead of
time and just hardwired in your system
and that's actually interesting problem
to to compute them I had to ask Don
onmouseover floor there's like an old
table called arrangement on arrangements
on chess boards or something it was
quite quite funny so they're yeah
they're related to sterling numbers of
the second kind of something but yeah so
you can't compute them ahead of time and
then plug them in there but these
constraints are kind of like different
from what you have in the network flow
but they are at least these coefficients
are always natural numbers so you don't
get any you know rationals there so in
practice you have the constraints are
solved very very quickly by a CLP and
and cplex MLP solve is slow I think it
has some like nonlinear behavior and
solving those bullies um you know good
pre-processing I would assume that cxn
cop21 on this network kind of
constraints so if you have like a large
program you know few hundred lines of
code and you look for balance of like a
higher decrease a three or four
then you can get fairly large constraint
systems you know like 1,000,000
constraints that's about the the
ballpark and yeah solving then takes one
minute and interestingly that's about
the time the solver needs to read in the
the constraints from a file if you would
give it to a file that's not what what
what we do but the the solving is almost
instantaneously and it takes about as
much time as like generating these
constraints that it takes for like
solving them so you know we are really
impressed by the by the lp solvers they
work really really well so okay so
that's all I have so I talked about this
automatically much highest resource
analysis that we developed it's very
precise as I hope I have demonstrated
because like the bounds of these
moderate resource polynomials that we
developed our very good at you know
describing precisely the cost of your
programs users our peaceful insufficient
we have a formal sound as proof with
respect to cost semantics and you can
even take the type derivation and ship
it with your program as a certificate of
the bound and we talked about non
polynomial balanced garbage collection
is still an open problem concurrency and
hardware models that's something we work
on and there's a weapon to face online
so if you want to try the analysis you
know you can go there type in some
programs and analyze them thank you
questions feel so so now that you have
this ability to so give a worst-case
bound for a program can you then say do
sort of like a what if scenario imagine
that there was some property of my
inputs I thought ought to be true so I'd
like to know how does that worst case
bound change you know on input subject
to this condition like I think that
maybe model that is sticking a beginning
part in the program just knocks out
inputs it to satisfy that condition
saying with the new works yeah
reasonable that would be reasonable to
do so long I thought to use this to them
say you know be able to take a
worst-case bound and say hi if I would
be so lucky then what satisfy such and
such how would that change yeah so
basically what you have to do is you
have to you know combine the analysis
with some you know technique for
reasoning about functional properties
you know and we did that already a
little bit so the question was kind of
like can you have some you know
constraints on your input and then maybe
get you know better bounce then you know
what you would get for like all possible
inputs to your to your program and the
answer is here guess that that's indeed
very helpful and sometimes it's even
necessary so we have a version of this
analysis here was just talking about the
functional case because I think it's a
bit more interesting with these data
structures and so on but like for the
work we do for instance for DARPA we
have to work with like low level code
mainly you know like this derive integer
bounds and so on and they're already we
need constraints on on the integers to
get a balance so for instance to give
you a simple example what we usually do
is we assign potential to intervals
between the the integers and then here
the list get smaller and you get out the
potential you can use it and there you
want to know that the interval gets
smaller but if the interval is already 0
right you you don't get anything out so
you need to have this information that
you know x is greater than y so that you
get something out of this interval
otherwise the analysis does not work to
come back to your question if it's I'm
not sure if I know an example that we
have yeah maybe there are like a few
where you even get
like where you can get a bound and then
if you have some logical constraint you
get a better bond i think that exists to
for these integer programs but yeah it's
a good question i don't know how to do
that for the functional our programs in
that in the systematic way by some of
these techniques or two that's it yeah
so I mean it's we tried that a little
bit but it's very very challenging and
the sense that like the worst case that
you have in these situations is usually
very bad and and so so that's you know
maybe another connection to the workshop
so that's then usually not so
interesting in terms of bounds that you
get so we applied that a little bit to
these lock-free log free data structures
and but we mainly so these are like data
structures you know that people use to
to you know excess excess share share
data without getting a walk before and
so they're mainly the goal was to prove
that they may progress but we did that
basically by deriving balance but the
balance we're very relatively useless so
what we try to do now is so there's like
a line of work in programming languages
called session types so Frank Fanning is
doing that so this is kind of like a way
where you specify the interaction of two
programs very precisely you say like ok
you send me this then I get that and
then I send you this and in this way
with which kind of like types and this
seems to be very promising approach if
you have these session type then you can
say like ok you know i sent you x and we
you know within five seconds then you
send me why after 10 seconds and in this
way I think we hopefully can get some
something useful and if more information
is available
yeah you can think of it like that yeah
yeah when can this kind of analysis be
done statically is for maybe two
straight line beyond or do you always do
this oh no no this is all mobile but I
showed us all statically so this is this
is a static analysis co so the only
thing we did dynamically with the
machine learning was to to get a high
level of semantics once once and for all
so then you know you know your average
vision costs you know 11 clock cycles
and from there you know we can you know
get you get your balance for for new
programs totally automatically of course
not for all programs you know but for
the ones I showed it works for instance
and it's also fairly intuitive i would
say for user who uses a system for a
while so it's not an arbitrary
heuristics so you get a feel for what
works and what doesn't work is pretty
transparent actually so that's also
something that's nice about it but of
course it's not a cyber problem and it's
hard to answer the question for what
programs it works and what not so let's
take for the questions offline so we
still get a break so thanks young